[Music]
all right he's back three years ago
about this time of year New York Times
bestselling author Peter Schweitzer he
launched the book number one New York
Times bestseller Clinton cash he's out
with a new investigative book it's
entitled secret empires how the American
political class hides corruption
enriches family and friends all right
let me just tell this audience cuz I've
read the book and you saw I had it
highlighted tonight that we're not gonna
get to the whole thing today I want to
give a broader overview and we'll do
what we did last time we're gonna break
it down one by one you were the first
guy to break your rhenium one you talked
about profit through proxy you talk
about Biden you talk about Kerry you
talk about Obama you talk about
Republicans Mitch McConnell right that's
exactly right
this is the new corruption Sean and this
is not the corruption of you know ninety
thousand dollars in your freezer this is
major amounts of money billions billions
of dollars in some cases and it involves
foreign governments who want to
influence our leaders and the way they
get around disclosures the way they get
around the law is they don't give the
money to the politician they don't even
give it to their spouse they give it to
their kids or they give it to a sibling
and that's a way that it avoids
detection the amounts of money you're
massive so for example there are three
major deals involving the Chinese
government and family members close
aides of the Secretary of State John
Kerry and the vice president's son a old
Biden's son and Joe Biden's son and
basically what happens is in 2013 Joe
Biden flies to China to talk to them
about very sensitive issues the South
China Sea talking about trade issues
economic issues hunter Biden his son is
with him on Air Force two okay that's
fine that's great here's the problem
ten days after they come back after Joe
Biden takes a pretty soft position
towards the Chinese hunter Biden ynx a
what becomes a 1.5 billion with a B
dollar détente look so he takes his son
to China yeah he just told at the time
if I remember that he's being soft on
China right exactly ten days later yes
his son got a what 1.5 billion dollar
private equity deal that's the first of
three 1.5 billion with a B that's right
billion with a B and that's
first of three deals Shaun there's
another deal this is one that involves
carries family it involves when it
carries aids and Hunter Biden its
Rosemont Seneca technology partners it's
an offshore fund Chinese government puts
38 million dollars into that third deal
Rosemont Realty again involving these
three same individuals it's a Chinese
government buys this real estate company
puts in three billion dollars I think
billions between these these three are
we talking about you're talking about if
you accumulate all of them you're
talking about multiple billions of
dollars at least a couple of billion
dollars and here's the problem Shawn
none of this was disclosed we have
pictures of it we have the documents but
it wasn't disclosed because federal law
doesn't require the vice-president's of
the last doorway like obama made a big
deal oh five year lobbying ban you know
right my you know what that's your lie
yeah because if Biden's son can go on
Air Force two and make a deal ten days
later for a billion and a half dollars
and this is the first of a number of
deals yes this is basically another way
to to buy influence that's exactly right
and that's why it's key we've got to
change the law there's got to be
disclosure right now Joe Biden gets a
$1,500 campaign contribution Sean he has
to disclose it his son gets a billion
and a half dollar private equity deal
from a foreign government
yeah no disclosure all right we're gonna
bring you back once a week and dig into
each one of these scandals one by one
but this is a big headline for our
audience and includes Mitch McConnell
right right you've got Mitch McConnell
his wife Elaine Chao very closely tied
commercially to the Chinese government
China's state shipbuilding corporation
largest military contractor in China
you've got close commercial ties there
and McConnell Senator McConnell in Lane
Chow got a gift from her father from
between five and twenty five million
dollars as a result of that Chinese
government and we're also gonna bring it
back on Obama his deals are a little
different and a little shady - all right
so you have on the cover of the book you
have you have a carry you have crazy
uncle Joe you've got McConnell
mama and Jared Kushner and I read the
chair at Kushner part and I'm thinking
oh boy he's in trouble but it was a lot
different heat this isn't the same why
did you put him on the cover if he's not
guilty of these same well Shawn we deep
scrub everybody Republicans Democrats
we've always done that McConnell should
be nervous about this yeah I think he
should be very nervous about this book
in the case of Jared Kushner look
there's no deals that have been
consummated we didn't find any foreign
deals what we did find though is the
Chinese government has said they don't
like President Trump's policies on the
military they don't like his policies on
trade and they explicitly said the way
we're gonna try to soften his position
is by going through the kids so we
really are it's it's a warning saying so
don't take these others did corrupt
deals you're just saying in Jared's case
you better learn from these guys don't
that's right don't you it's gonna be
damaging to the family it's gonna be
damaging to the country all right this
book secret empires bestseller
amazon.com Hannity calm bookstores
everywhere Peter good to see